okay so just like last time I'm gonna do
my real opinion with the bum review and
before I start this week I want just a
question everybody's asking how come in
the bum review you always do spoilers
but as yourself you don't spoil anything
the reason for that is because I assume
most people who see the bum review have
seen the movie already so and the bum
even says flat out their spoilers in
this Michael I said if you haven't seen
the film somebody may want to see my
review and see what I think before they
go see it so I'm not going to give
anything away at least as much as I can
so the bum does boiler as I do not so
with that said pirates let's talk about
the new pirates movie um it's a little
difficult to review but probably the
best thing to do real fast is tell you
what I thought of the other three films
give you some context first film I like
I don't think was a masterpiece or
anything but it was fun good mindless
entertainment it's a popcorn movie
that's my definition of a popcorn movie
uh the second and third I thought got
really long and needlessly complicated
it didn't need to be this long and like
everyone I didn't think they needed to
still have our land of bloom and keira
knightley just go off which I def on his
adventures like they're finally doing
here
um I didn't hate them as much as a lot
of other people did but I do agree with
the problems everybody pointed out but I
thought there was so much creativity in
them I I don't regret seeing them are
the good movies probably not I don't
regret seeing them I'm glad I saw them
so with that said this film pretty much
falls into a lot of the same traps that
those other two films did with some
exceptions the fact that they don't have
orlando bloom and keira knightley is a
big plus I hate saying that cuz I'm sure
they're nice people but uh they just
they really sucked out a lot of the
energy of these movies when it should
have been on Jack Sparrow this one is on
Jack Sparrow and he's in it these
bunnies hamming it up to the camera and
he's really great
Jeffrey brush is in it again again great
love that guy whatever him and Deb are
together wonderful uh one newcomer that
they have is a Penelope Cruz this is
what Keira Knightley should have been
this was a really fun character
this was you know some puts on the
pirate suit and you know has the the
cool accent and is really tough really
funny really clever and backstabbing
that's what I well then all these boys
all of the backstabbing that's
constantly going on through these movies
so that was a great addition uh what
doesn't work the stuff where they fall
into the same traps is that it is still
needlessly complicated these plots and
stories that they have going on they
don't need so much especially at least
with the other three you could argue
they're big films they're huge
do they work not really but they're big
huge films so they try throw everything
in it here this is kind of a smaller
story and which is a good idea but they
still make it like whatever two and a
half hours or at least it felt like two
and a half hours and they have all the
really you know needlessly complicated
stuff there's even one point where Jack
Sparrow sysm oh that sounds really
complicated you needlessly complicate
and he's right if Sony was ly
complicated and they don't have to do
that so those are the big problems and
there's the biggest shock to me here's
another really big problem for me was
that they build up this villain that
they build a black beard I don't think
I'm giving anything away but everyone
knows he's in this and they really build
him up and they do a good job building
up this bad guy you don't see him on
this ship and there's talk whether he's
even on the ship and finally the doors
open up and there he is just see his
boots it pants up his beard sir has
these little flames on he's drinking his
rum or whatever at it alright here we go
boring character surprisingly boring and
two reasons for that one he's not
written very interestingly it's not you
know this is Blackbeard and we don't
even know much about him we just you
know he sort of supernatural but not
really he's zombify his people but if he
can do that why is he looking for the
Fountain of Youth just zombify himself
that doesn't make sense uh so it's the
writing and also I hate to say the
acting is not so hot it's not terrible
the guy who plays them I'm blanka's name
but he doesn't do a god-awful job or
anything it's just not that interesting
it's this
very dull performance and I figure if
they got someone like an Anthony Hopkins
or James Earl Jones how cool would that
be to play this part they would have
brought something to this but as is this
is a very not interesting villain um so
that was a major major problem uh not
now that was the really bad stuff the
good stuff uh the mermaids are awesome
I'm gonna repeat that because you're
rarely going to hear me say that about a
movie the mermaids are awesome they're
sort of like a mix between mermaids and
vampires sort of which sounds stupid but
it's actually pretty cool and they make
them really intimidating you know they
they look great they're these beautiful
women that you know seduce the men they
bring them down and they eat their faces
off you know and they they fly out of
the water grab people they have whips
mermaids have lips I mean that's friggin
cool so that stuff was great um the lady
said the stuff with the actors hamming
it up to the camera it is a lot of fun
Penelope Cruz Jeffrey Rogers Johnny Depp
they're all having fun or at least it
looks like they're having fun
something else I noticed about the other
pirate movies is that they're they look
nice but they're they're shot nights but
they're very dirty and I think they're
supposed to be dirty you know and serve
ugly-looking uh it's nice to see a
cleaner pirate film because after why
it's better for film that's so long if
they were sure to be okay but the
faidley's films are so long there's only
so much dirt and slime and grease enos
and stuff that you can see on screen so
it's nights in this film looks cleaner
um so that's a plus that's a weird thing
to praise a movie for um and I like I
said that even though they got rid of
Orlando bloomin Keira Knightley they
have a similar storyline going on on the
side which everybody you could
practically hear everybody in the
audience groan every time to come back
to this and that's with this clergyman
and one of the mermaids and it's it's
not needed it's pretty pointless again
every time it cuts back to them
everybody groans as a come on just get
back to Jack Sparrow better um I said
that storyline and the black beard or
anything have
do a Blackbeard leisa was very dull
there Penelope Cruz has this connection
to Blackbeard and it just slows down the
story and it's not interests they seem
very off character for her um and
there's a lot of things now this or goes
with all the pirate movies but this one
this one serve especially is that
there's a lot of there suspension of
disbelief and then there's cutting the
bungee cord of disbelief because this
really really pushes it there's a scene
again without giving too much away where
somebody's posing as Jack Sparrow in the
opening and nobody nobody will believe
this is Jack Sparrow
nobody would fall for it and the fact
that they try to make us believe yet
everybody's falling that this is Jack
Sparrow and that words getting around is
nobody can believe it nobody would be
able to buy that uh there's also like I
said there's eenz were um a black beer
cans Amba five people but he's looking
for the Fountain of Youth well why does
he need the Fountain of Youth if he can
zombify people he can also control this
ship he puts his sword on the whole ship
moves what it seems like that could
solve a lot of problems other times the
guards of course you know have guns and
don't use them half the time that
there's a lot of those really stupid
action cliches and here I think it sort
of pushes it but I I think I enjoyed it
I was willing to forgive it a lot of
people probably won't um so with that
said is it as bad as say pirates Riggs I
know a lot of people really hate piracy
I don't think it's that bad I don't
think it's as bad as critics are saying
it is I think they're probably just
tired of the same problem coming up and
I agree with that I it's like come on
you almost had this because I'm watching
this movie it's starting out a lot of
fun action a lot of hamming it up and
it's by the middle you're finally
starting to groan okay come I just get
to the frigging fountain there's a scene
where they're debating whether or not
giant dip should jump off this cliff and
if he'll survive and then they they pick
these six guns and whether or not black
leader is gonna shoot a Penelope Cruz
I'm like why doesn't he just jump this
that should easily be cut out so
there's a last thing as they easily
could have cut out but with that said
like the other pirate movies there's a
lot of creativity a lot of good jokes a
lot of good action my thought is that if
you like the other pirate movies if you
like all of them you'll probably like
this one fine if you're sick to death of
the pirate movies if you're just done
with it you don't want to see any more I
don't think you're gonna like this I
don't think you'll hate it but I think
you're gonna throw up your arms and just
be undone stop it you know no more of
this so because I'm sort of an optimist
on you know anything creative and like I
like seeing the mermaids I like seeing
these actors I like Penelope Cruz um I
I'm glad I saw it I don't think I'd see
it again um and I think the only other
thing I'll talk about terms of complaint
is that the ending is where I'm bringing
Penelope Cruz so much good oh I saw I
don't have a thing for her it's just a
good character but the ending that they
give this character it's not deserved
and it's out of character for both uh
Jack Sparrow character and her character
it's just like no this makes no sense
this especially the way they build it up
it does not add up
it really doesn't come together uh
there's a final thing after the credits
that's cute you know that they do with
her but at the same time you just go
back that didn't add up that didn't that
that really didn't mesh wall that this
character deserves something better so
yeah so I like I said my final thought
is that it's not as bad to say like
pirates three but it's nowhere near as
good as the first one and if you're if
you're a huge Pirates fan and you you
want to go see it you'll probably like
it okay if you're sick to death of the
pirate films and you're just saying they
better impress me of this one you're
probably not gonna get much out of it I
don't know if you'll despise it but
you're not gonna get much out of it so
uh that's my take on the pirate films if
you don't agree with me that five you
want to find out for yourself go see it
that's my opinion and that's all I got
I'll see you next review